okay so I've created a segment for you
today okay that's called um not totally
100% should we do an intro this is how
my channel works John know I've seen you
be
hey cheers Cheers gee it's grace hey the
best YouTube channel ever hmm Oh Bevers
delicious which brings me to the name of
this segment it's called brutally honest
Oh brew I see it's a pun yeah okay
did you ever spend time with Hannah Hart
and mamrie no Oh seem like they're just
one giant period mm-hmm of a time um
wasn't a good fun no it wasn't at all
that's why I should be spending more
time with him so okay I like your eyes
oh yeah it's very my New Jersey's coming
out a lot more with my age in that I'm
putting more and more black eyeliner on
it did you just say that my new jersey
is coming out more and more yeah I mean
that would be the title of my porn that
exists somewhere yeah I'm so excited I
mean the best thing about having The
Fault in Our Stars movie come out is
that it dramatically increases the
chance that there will be a Fault in Our
Stars porn parody what would it be
called I don't know I'm not very good at
puns no we're gonna have to actually I
think the porn companies are now hiring
maimry
oh I'm sure yeah she's going through
storyboards right now uh now I'm so
distracted okay anyway so this segment
is basically just I'm gonna ask you a
bunch of questions and you be as honest
as you want about them yep did you know
prior to your wife having a child that
women like [ __ ] themselves while they
have birth they don't always well
probably like always
they don't always but like no they don't
always every woman that has had a child
is like nope put it all out there nope
okay
lots of times not always you so the
percentage of her having that experience
is upped math sense um did you know this
though prior to your wife having a child
uh that was serious like number one
anxiety going into delivery more than
more than having to push a child out of
out of her special place yeah was this
thought of of potentially yes more so
she was very anxious about it and
everything worked out better than
expected okay well that's great
I'm happy for her and for you because I
just imagine like I missed the miracle
of life video in my CCD class yeah he's
in like sixth grade yeah I've never seen
childbirth happen except on like TLC
sure and yeah they conveniently left
that information out I only learned this
like six months ago it's very upsetting
for years you and Sarah both I was
already like I kept telling her it's not
a big deal there's gonna be so much
other weird stuff happening there I'm
gonna feel it a doctor's see it all the
time when a doctor is looking at your
vagina to begin with they're already
very exposing I didn't know we were
gonna start there well I thought that
we're gonna talk about my movie no it's
not about your movie I'm talking about
I'm not I've talked about it for like
three weeks straight I don't don't even
mention it g6 June 6th yay five days
after my mother's birthday happy
birthday to Grace's mother wait five
days to celebrate got it um no I figure
you've been talking about it for so
correct and I have not talked about
pooping on the delivery table Oh single
time yeah always like what question
haven't I asked and from now on I'm
gonna be like you have to ask me about
pooping on the delivery table once yeah
how dare you what kind of reporter are
you seriously I just like feel like my
interview skills are
of and beyond what a normal interviewer
would offer correct yeah so along those
lines
what do you honestly think about Beyonce
I'm a massive Beyonce fan are you
I think that she is one of the five or
six most important people in the history
of the world
I would say like Genghis Khan Alexander
the Great um whoever invented fire yeah
um Cleopatra Beyonce and Beyonce yeah
you're not a Beyonce fan no I love
Beyonce she's just I I'm also scared
what if she watches this and she finds
out what he comments negative about her
does she she's a big it's Grayson yeah
she's not surprised she likes great
taste I know except for her documentary
she blogged in that documentary did you
ever watch it um not a good vlogger no
she edited the whole documentary himself
not a good blogger one poor head
position and just go too low on the
screen like this no she gets too close
oh yeah I do that sometimes where I get
really really not good I thought that
was good no it's good but it was like
the whole time and then she just didn't
use jump cuts the way like jump cuts
could be helpful yeah um and also there
was just I turned off the documentary
half way through at the part where her
and jay-z are on a yacht and there's
just a foot clip of jay-z holding a
camera and he just pushes it into her
eye and then pulls it back out and like
sing at the most like artistic music
behind and I was like nope I'm out ha ha
ha channel it was tough but I do think
Beyonce is a wonderful wonderful
performer
and sometimes when I want to be inspired
i rewatch her performance where she told
jay-z that she was pregnant oh my god
wasn't that beautiful that is beautiful
but then you know what happened nine
months later she [ __ ] on a table
somewhere I didn't say it Beyonce like
and subscribe Beyonce okay here's a
question what job do you never want your
child to have okay so you know how some
people jump out of airplanes and then
they use the parachutes right do you
know how the people like if you haven't
jumped out of an airplane before you are
tied to a person oh yeah the tandem a
professional parachute jumper yes I do
not want my child ever to be a
professional parachute jumper that's an
excellent answer
yeah that's an excellent excellent
answer you've thought about this and the
other thing is that I don't ever want to
skydive because that would mean that I
was tied to someone who's a professional
parachute jumper and I don't trust their
career choices no I don't trust them
getting a boner midair oh god I never
went there you're stuck there for like
four minutes yeah I know one
experiencing complete fear and then an
euphoria and then it's just ruined
awesome I don't know I mean in some ways
it's more fear and for you for you I
mean I guess it would take your mind off
the fact that you could die it'd be like
this is what what's up hey hey oh that's
a carabiner oh I hope that's just one of
the hooks that came loose haha I hope
that's the parachute I'm not deploying
what's a youtube video you wish you
never saw oh there's a lot of them
really like what um a lot of the animals
eating animals Oh what well you're just
like unexpected snake eats a crocodile
oh that's a subgenre I have not explored
yeah yeah and then I'm not very keen on
the the gigantic guns blowing up the
gigantic watermelons or whatever oh oh I
don't do that no I mean no I don't like
guns here I saw one by accident where a
guy shot himself in the knee oh now he's
upsetting that well you know just don't
put a gun in your pocket no dramatic
aliy increases your chances of not
shooting yourself in the need is
NBA career no no I know yeah
what's one that you wish you'd never
seen glass in the ass what yeah don't do
not what it sounds like uh you know who
showed me Tyler Oakley how is that up
and take it off
uh I think that we actually watched it
on another website because it wasn't
allowed on YouTube but a long story
short a whole seemingly super long video
short a guy puts a P ed glass cup up his
butthole and it breaks inside go gone
and turnip you know the move way up you
know the movie there will be blood come
on Oh Hannah I know okay grace this put
our friendship in real danger just by
the fact that you mentioned that yeah
I'm sorry
I'd liked you a lot until then okay you
know what you know what what video
doesn't feature anything like that what
The Fault in Our Stars movie coming out
on June 6th and theaters everywhere no
one dares to put a glass in their ass in
that movie um now it's a movie about
different kinds of disabilities okay
this got to serious if you really want a
good time meat loaf arts what you doing
you know farts exactly what it sounds
like
woman's farting naked on meatloaf not on
YouTube now it's definitely not on
YouTube well no there's a whole website
called cake farts calm this is like the
one the branch off from it so there's
cake for women for don't cake and then
they branch off and they also fired on
meatloaf some people something to get
curious okay how many fingers do you
think we need ha ha ha hey I'm deeply
upset about the meatloaf arts situation
you just want to move on two fingers
yeah I mean the most upsetting thing is
like there are children that are
starving that would have loved that
meatloaf
six I think we need six fingers [ __ ]
yeah one hand goes three total three on
you change yeah yeah cuz that I could I
could still write and I could do most of
things that I still text
yeah you could text and hold your phone
and I think you'll be fine with six
these two are the opposite ease are the
optional ones at the end but then what
becomes a wedding finger oh yeah that's
a big concern for you yeah yeah concern
by the way grace is engaged I'm engaged
in conversation right now without John
Green his movie The Fault in Our Stars
comes out on June 6th would you rather
have no arms or no legs no arms no yeah
really yeah what about you well then why
did you ask it a question because I
could um I would think I think another
thing you can do with arms think of all
the things you can do with legs but I
would get to robot legs because science
is very advanced well if you can get
proba that that changes the hypothetical
completely and no legs okay
well but also like I see those jazzy
chair commercials not familiar Oh
jazzy chair is a it's trying to make a
wheelchair more fun and it is invented
no lie by a man named Tom Cruise and he
is the same Tom Cruise no that guy is
just so versatile I know no it might be
in which you such things brilliant
ding but the commercial introduced by a
guy that says hello I'm Tom Cruise the
creator of the chassis what do you got
the same Tom Cruise I also always feel
so bad for people named like Lance
Armstrong or beyonce knowles or whatever
like yeah so hard
hey but are like Oprah Oprah Winfrey
yeah I like the second Oprah Winfrey
sloodle oh that would be terrible
yeah speaking of so hard to Google
yourself when you're the other that's
give me the name of my television show
the other you can have your own Gayle
Hannah Hart's gonna play your game yeah
my girl played by Hannah Hart um
speaking of Oprah and the YouTube videos
have you ever seen over making water
have I have you it's a 10-minute looped
clip from the color purple where Oprah's
peeing in a hole
it's just looped enman am i repeating in
a hole in the ground it's really good
I'm just giving you an educational
experience I guess so yeah there's a
whole world that I didn't know about
thank you for this oh oh you really want
a good like sub-genre of YouTube videos
you don't think I do you do on this one
um it's men falling off boats that
sounds great actually
I love when people fall it's great wait
are they all okay they're all fine okay
I'm a great earned about they're safe
no it's always like them with one foot
on a dock and one foot on a boat and the
boat starts to pull away and then they
have there is nothing funnier than
watching other people suffer non serious
injuries Oh falling down I realized it's
like my when someone's like what's the
funniest thing to you the world falling
down strangers who fault anyone that for
even someone I love like when Sam puts
there there's a there's a there's a
secret step in our house that causes us
both to fall but books a week okay um
and when Sarah falls on that step she
just every time just you know she's
midair and she's just stunned it she
doesn't know what to do and she's trying
to catch it just trying to get her legs
out from under and it's beautiful and I
just I can't help but laugh and then I'm
like are you alright I just did so
enjoyable I that's why we've got ever
got the step
oh yeah you need it it's your life yeah
it's good for a marriage I think that
it's that's true um I fall all the time
I'm just a clumsy person by nature yeah
I have this image in my head of my mom
when I was in like fifth or sixth grade
I got a pogo stick my mom went to use it
for the first time and she jumped once
my brain forever beautiful oh it's
really great um do have do you remember
your what is your first childhood memory
I remember eating I remember having my
it's terrible I remember having my face
pushed in the in the in the ground in
the playground and being made to eat
dirt when I was five Wow yeah do you
remember the person that did that to you
I do
do you wish them no I know they were
five I once Mike said something nasty
about someone who'd bullied me in in
elementary school and they wrote me a
really great letter and bit that one of
the lines in the letter has always stuck
with me which is I'm really sorry that I
would mean to you in elementary school
but I was nine what's your Excuse what
which is so true like it is really hard
to be nine no matter what so you can't
judge people for being nine
underdeveloped brain yeah it's hard I
know I was really mean to a girl at make
fun of one of my videos once on tumblr
and then she shut out her tumblr and I
felt so oh yeah what you realize is that
those it's really easy to dehumanize
people on the internet it's really hard
to remember that everybody is a person
yeah I know now when I look at negative
comments I just realized like oh there's
clearly some things that's sad in their
life that they're going through that I
should not even try to communicate with
totally possible that this is not
actually about me yeah no absolutely for
to understand that there are things in
the world that aren't about me but there
are there's a bunch of I know I was
thinking of painting my walls in the day
when I realized that all my walls are
just mirrors whoa beautiful grace thank
you maybe do a little something on the
inside just like The Fault in Our Stars
movie will make you feel something on
June 6th I heard how's the last one
what's that
how's the last one I was last look I
that was basically the last question no
way yeah oh no I'm sad I thought you're
gonna ask me how many toes how many
really you'd fall forward all the time
in but then that'd be great because
you'd be like this a human clown and
giving everyone joy thanks for watching
it's great I don't know you have
anything else till I love that ending
Falmer stars June 6 at a theater near
you you will weep says Hannah Hart via
text message yesterday bring tissues bye
bye